today's one minute monday is
connect with people you cannot do
this business on your own okay to build
something great
you need to connect with people and get
people to help you grow
every time i go away to another city i
try to connect with the people on my
newsletter people who
are fans see if i can help them out in
any way i just got back from orlando
speaking at a conference and i had a
crazy packed schedule i had a morning
two hour session i was leading
then a lunch that was a networking lunch
i was hosting
did an afternoon two-hour session i was
leading then
a dinner and an events award where i had
to
present the award for best social media
and
and then i wanted to go salsa dancing of
course after right so it was a crazy
late night
and i thought wow i have no time how am
i going to connect with people on my
newsletter list like i always like to do
i don't think i'm going to be able to do
it because i had to leave the next day
and i thought you know what
i got to find a way i gotta find a way
to do it because i love connecting with
people
and the only time i had was the morning
the day of my flight it was sunday
morning
nine a.m i said you know what if people
want to come meet me for sunday 9 a.m
coffee
i'll meet with them and i put out a
notice to my newsletter list and i met
mike and dave two amazing entrepreneurs
from orlando we had a great conversation
i was able to connect with them help
them grow their business they both
left super happy and overwhelmed and
mike even gave me a ride to the airport
after
thank you mike so connect with people
even if you have a crazy schedule like
we all have you need to find
time in your week every single week to
connect with people reach out to them
try to make their lives better see how
they can help you with your business
because you cannot
do this all on your own you need the
support of the people in your network
believe for those who watching like the
video thumbs up below
support me by the link below leave a
comment subscribe to the channel i'll
see you soon